here in South Africa doctors called
sangomas treat millions of people using
creature cures meet Elliot in lovoo the
Zulu sangoma from kannberg village in
the mountains of kwazulu-natal Elliot
doesn't just use herbs in animal body
parts arbitrarily all sangomas are
guided by the spirits of their ancestors
to become a traditional doctor it's a
calling that come from my assistance so
I was been called before I come to this
world it is the traditional African
belief that most illness is caused by
witchcraft or the spirits of displeased
ancestors it is the job of the sangoma
as a medium between the spirit world and
our own to appease the ancestors or
chase away the evil forces causing the
ailment today Samson one of the older
members of the community comes to Elliot
for help he is having problems with
pains in his legs instead of prescribing
painkillers Elliot must make the
medicine on himself fortunately he has
the key ingredient on hand a baboon
carcass it is a traditional African
belief that animal qualities can be
transferred to the patient the pop one
is a strongest enemy because even its
bones is too strong to capture the
powers of the baboon a traditional
medicine called a mu T is made from the
skin and tail and mixed with herbs the
limb of the baboon will also be boiled
for drinking these mu T's will allow Sam
C's legs to take on the strength of the
baboon and ease his pains
Samson inhales and licks the burning
baboon mixture while waiting for the
limb to boil the strength of Samson's
belief in the powers of the baboon parts
already seems to be having an effect if
this feels bad days feeling things going
around sangomas have lifelong experience
with medicinal plants and many are
expert herbalists but the patient's
belief in the sangoma and his remedies
is an important part of the cure
dr. Conrad Jionni's office in muttsy
north of Johannesburg is a far cry from
the rural beginnings of sangoma with
computers copying machines secretaries
and assistants
he has brought traditional healing into
the 21st century I feel we are not
competing with that I'm one doctors I
feel in some other instances that very
much superior to us yet they miss many
things out of us so I feel that we can
supplement each other instead of
reaching for a stethoscope to diagnose
what's wrong with his patients dr.
Gianni throws animal bones through the
bones dr. Gianni deciphers the message
sent by the ancestors this is for lash
in the stomach and we normally use a
chicken doctor Jionni's patient blows
air into the chickens this method may
seem unusual but there is a rationale
it is believed Selby's illness will now
be inside the chicken
dr. Gianni does not claim his methods
will hold up to scientific scrutiny but
we don't address until available we are
traditionally an uncertain